what we're going to try to do in this
video is find the area of this figure
and we can see it's a quadrilateral it
has one two three four sides and we know
that this side and this side that
they're parallel to each other you can
see that they both form right angles
with this dotted line so pause this
video and see if you can find the area
all right now if you had a little bit of
trouble with that i'll give you a hint
what if we were to take this
quadrilateral and divide it into two
triangles so let me do this in a color
that you are likely to see
so if i were to draw a line
like this
it now divides the quadrilateral into
two triangles if i were to take
this triangle right over here
i could take it out and reorient it so
it looks something
it looks something like this
where
the base
has length eight
and then the height right over here
the height
this has length five so that would be
that triangle and then this triangle
over here
if you were to take it out and reorient
it a little bit it could look like this
where the base is for
and the triangle
looks something like
looks something like this so the base
is four
and then the height is going to be five
so this height right over here
this height we know this is a right
angle so from here to here which is the
same thing as from here
to right over here we know that this is
five so that's my fairly big hint to you
if you know how to find the area of a
triangle
the area of a triangle we know is
one half base times height so the area
of this one right over here is going to
be one half
times eight
times five
and the area of this one over here is
going to be one-half
times the base which is four
times the height which is five
and we could evaluate each of these or
we could just add them together that the
area of the entire thing is going to be
one-half
times this base right over here which is
8 times the height which is 5
plus
plus
1 half
times this side you could do that as the
other base
times 4
times that same height times 5 and
obviously you could just evaluate this
or we could see some interesting things
about it we could express this as well
if we were to
factor out a one-half and the five year
this could be rewritten as
one-half
times eight plus four
eight
plus
four
and then all of that
all of that times
five right over here and so another way
you could think about it is the average
of the length of these two bases you
could view this as base 1 and base 2 you
multiply that times the height and you
have the area of this quadrilateral well
what's that going to be 8 plus 4 is 12
one half times 12 this is all going to
be 6 6 times 5 is going to be equal to
30 square units you could have figured
it out here too one half times 8 is 4
times five is twenty and then this would
have been one half times four is two
times five is ten twenty plus ten is
thirty square units once again